-Our first guest tonight
is a 5-time NFL MVP,
14-time Pro Bowler,
2-time Super Bowl champion
Super Bowl MVP
and was recently elected t
the Pro Football
Hall of Fame.
He hosts "Capital One
College Bowl,"
premiering next Tuesday at 10p
right here on NBC.
Please welcome to the show
one of the greatest to eve
play the game,
Peyton Manning.
It is so nice to see you,
Peyton.
-Seth, thanks for having me,
man, appreciate it.
-Such a pleasure.
Congratulations, so much,
on your induction
into the Hall of Fame.
Obviously, you were a studen
of the history of this game.
You were aware
that your accomplishments
were Hall of Fame worthy.
But with that said,
was it still incredibly exciting
to get the news?
-It sure was, Seth.
You know, normally they le
the Hall of Famers know
by knocking on their hotel doo
down at the Super Bowl site.
Due to COVID,
they cancelled that,
so they actually came out to
Denver and they told each --
each of the inductees that the
were being inducted.
And my wife, Ashley, kind of
set up where I had about
five of my coaches --
my college coaches,
my NFL coaches, my high school
coach did a video.
They were the ones that,
kind of, told me
I'd been inducted
into the Hall of Fame,
so it's like 30 years
of coaching of memories
right in front of you
in that moment,
so it really
did make it special.
It's been a great time
to reflect,
think about all the people
that have been
a part of this journey.
It's been a lot of fun
these past few months.
-It was a really special moment.
They did a great job
pulling it together for the fans
to watch, too.
I know you have twin boys,
they're 10-years-old.
They were very young when yo
were playing.
I know they like football. I
know they like Patrick Mahomes
Are they impressed that thei
dad is a Hall of Famer.
-Well, actually, I have
boy-girl twins --
-Oh, excuse me, sorry.
-10-years-old.
Marshall and Mosley, both bi
football fans, naturally.
My son, particularly,
is a big Mahomes fan,
Josh Allen fan.
These kids wear Jerseys
all the time.
It's hard to take a kid wearin
a Chiefs Jersey to school,
but since he's related to me
Seth, I feel like I have to.
I can't just drop him off,
you know, far away.
You know, my son done a little
school report a few weeks ag
saying he was --
saying that I was
one of his favorite quarterbacks
and so that made me feel good.
I feel secure in my competitio
with Mahomes and Allen,
but I think it's good for thes
kids to have a current
favorite player, right,
wear a jersey.
I was a Dan Marino fan
after my dad retired.
I think it's good
as long as you're,
you know, fans of the game
-Well, it's both impressiv
that you're a first-ballot
Hall of Famer and one of
your son's favorite players.
[ Light laughter ]
-I think that.
-Yes. Yes. Thank you.
-It's really -- it's gonna b
fun watching you host this
We're, obviously,
very aware that you are known,
not just for your football
skills, but your sense of humor.
So you're hosting
"Capital One College Bowl.
Your brother, Cooper,
sort of,
one of the lesser-known
Mannings.
I was lucky enough to get to
meet him when you did "SNL" --
kind of, secretly, one of th
funniest guys out there.
-Yeah, he also says he's
the best-looking Manning,
so that's debatable.
It's a lot of fun, Seth, for me.
I know you can appreciate --
Cooper and I don't get to spen
all that much time
together anymore.
Living in Colorado,
living in New Orleans.
We spent eight days together i
Los Angeles filming this show.
We laughed a lot.
We had so much fun interacting
with these students.
Super smart kids,
but funny and engaging.
They, like, give it back t
Cooper, which I really enjoyed
and it's, kind of, like --
it's a different type of gam
show, Seth.
It's, kind of, like he and I
we were in our basement
hosting a big game of
trivia pursuit and --
oh, it just happens
to be on TV.
But yet, we're still havin
these side conversations
that have nothing to do with the
actual game, but I think he,
kind of, kept
the students light.
He kept them
from getting nervous
and the students seemed to
enjoy it.
So it was a lot of fun to do
and the fact they were
playing for scholarships
made it all worthwhile.
-Yeah, this is 'cause --
"College Bowl" is a, sort of
an old show but one of the new
revamped details of it
is you were giving out, I guess,
million dollars in scholarship
And these are smart kids
to begin with,
so this money is going to --
to good use.
-Yeah, that's, kind of,
what hooked me --
I never thought I'd be the hos
of a game show.
I'm not sure if I'm a very goo
host to tell you the truth
I was butchering some words,
some names.
The students still got the
question right
even though I pronounced
the key ingredient wrong.
It tells you how smart they are.
But Seth,
being a part of scholarships
for a long time
at my alma mater,
it's some HBCU's --
it's life changing, right?
It changes the course
of a family.
Now they can send
that student's younger sibling
to college because of this
scholarship money.
So to see their reaction o
these kids' faces,
every kid got something.
The winning team, obviously,
got the most.
Almost a four-year ride
scholarship.
It was pretty powerful to
witness and that's really wh
I got involved.
-Now I'm -- I'm surprised to
hear that you would make
any errors, Peyton,
because, one, you're known -
in your playing career, you were
known as being very prepared
I've often told people I never
saw a "SNL" host who had
a more advanced binder syste
for the sketches.
Everything was color coded
When people came in to give yo
a line change,
you were ready for it.
Did you do a lot of
prep for this?
Did you -- you know,
did you treat it like
game day each episode?
-I certainly did.
You know, it was difficult
because due to the game show
integrity rules, we couldn't
get the questions til, like,
an hour and a half
before the show.
And, you know, Cooper might've
been selling those
out on the street in L.A. to
fellow UCLA alums
to help their team win.
But for me, Seth,
it really was challenging.
I literally had an hour-long
pronunciation meeting
just to figure out
how to pronounce it.
And I was telling the person
working on that, I said,
"Here's how I want you to spel
it in the monitor."
Some really phonetic spellin
that was pretty special.
I'm like, "That's the only way
I'm going to
pronounce it correctly."
So I tried to do
the best I could.
I tried to, kind of,
stay out of the way
where I wouldn't screw it up
Cooper was right in his
wheelhouse,
having quick one-liners.
So I was a little uncomfortable,
I will admit, to start,
but I enjoyed it as it went on
Especially as we got to
the finals,
as these teams were really
kind of, laying it on
the line trying to win these
scholarships.
It was pretty cool.
-As somebody who, you know
spent a career of reading
a defense,
could you clock quickly
which of these teams
were the real deal as soon a
you started seeing them
answering questions as soo
as you saw them,
sort of, talking to each other
-Yeah, you certainly could
I mean, there were certain
students who just jumped out
I mean, they were answerin
every single question.
I mean, one time, I might've
said, like, "What is --"
and the kid is like, "Korea.
And I'm like, "I didn't even -
I didn't even give anything.
[ Laughter ]
And so, it was impressive.
And like I said,
they were super smart,
but also engaging and funny.
A lot of pride in their
universities, right?
We got Alabama versus Albany
in the opening match, right.
Great rivalry, great competitive
juices flowing,
but also very respectable
amongst each other,
so it was really,
really special to witness.
-You know, you asked --
obviously,
a large breath of categories
on the show like this.
A lot of stuff
that you would expect
smart kids to have learned
in school.
There a few, you know,
pop culture questions.
Is there any blind spots
for these kids?
Is there anything
they don't know?
-Yeah, I mean,
the thing we wanted to do --
it's not good if a kid jus
doesn't know the answer
or the other team
don't know the answer.
It's just bad TV, right?
If no one knows the answer
So we tried to ask about
relevant people.
People that everybody, you know,
probably should know.
The audience at home
should know,
but they're super smart kids
Every now and then,
something comes up
that they just don't know
anything about, which was,
you know, kind of,
disappointing and surprising
but based on the subject,
I, kind of, understand it.
I actually brought a clip, Seth.
-Oh, great.
-And I'll show you one example
-Alright, let's take a look.
-What former
"Saturday Night Live"
head writer hosts the talk show,
"Late Night"?
-Edgar Allen Poe.
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
-Elton John.
[ Buzzer ]
-That is incorrect.
-Jane Seymour.
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
-The Lone Ranger.
-I see what you've done here
and I do not appreciate it
[ Buzzer ]
-No, no, no. Time is up.
One final chance.
Anyone can buzz in to answer
-Seth Meyers.
-Oh, good. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-I could've sworn
it was Jane Seymour.
I all most said --
-Yeah, I mean,
that's a really --
that's a classic either or
Hey, Peyton, it's always
a delight to see you.
Congrats on the show,
I can't wait to watch it,
and look forward to
the next time.
-Seth, thanks pal.
Good to see you.
-"Capital One College Bowl
premieres Tuesday
June 22nd at 10pm here on NBC.